let's talk about the 33 this is the true
story of 33 Chilean miners a famous
story who were all trapped in a mine
collapse and they were trapped for how
long
69 days I'm sure they're not proud of it
but they hold the record yeah yeah and
it's an absolutely incredible story and
you were in this movie with Antonio but
at Paris you two are working in tight
quarters you must have gotten to know
Antonio quite well let me tell you
ladies I get it now I get it
this is what it's like to do is see with
Antonio Banderas Lou if I may call you
Lou you're going to be doing very
intimate see we are going to take off
our shirts we are going to be very dirty
and sweaty we're going to touch each
other in a manly way and the panties
come right off
[Applause]
Varys is the Pied Piper of panties I've
ever been is yes that's incredible yes
why were you wearing ka why were you
wearing happy it mitigates the badass
higher being stereotype exactly dark
ethnic you know in the movie your
character is responsible for mine safety
and making sure the mine is safe and
you've got all these concerns about the
mine and no one listens to you and then
finally when this terrible accident
happens you really feel responsible
throughout the entire time that all of
you are trapped down there it feels like
your job big job as an actor is to
remotely that feeling of great weight
and responsibility sir sue he's a
wonderful man Don Lucho
he was the shift supervisor and when and
he did warn them about safety when the
mine collapsed he was guilt-ridden he
was overwhelmed with the responsibility
and we shot in real mines in Bogota
Colombia and in the Atacama Desert in
Chile we were shooting about a month and
then we took a Christmas break and I got
home and I realized I was channeling my
dog your dog I don't know how it
happened but I was channeling my dog my
dog he's guilt-ridden if you call his
name he'll look at your like what did I
do
did I do something wrong I know it I'm
in trouble I know I'm in trouble I
crapped on the carpet I crapped on the
carpet I forgot all about it that's his
name your dog
Quetzal got a photo of kit so and this
is feeling so you're saying that you
were let's see how well you were
channeling him this is
[Laughter]
you know some people that go Genaro they
go with Brando kids till the dog doesn't
like touch stuff that is this roll that
was the scene to where your character
shits on the carpet wasn't that a great
clip subscribe to my youtube channel for
an endless supply of me
[Laughter]